hi guys it's Dave here from gamespot for
e3 2016 joined by Jimmy who has played
fallout 4 in a bit of a new experience
fallout vr right yes so I was really
excited to hear that but as it was
bringing fallout 2 VR at the same time
there was a little bit worried as a VR
enthusiast I know that games can be I
can induce motion sickness if they're
not done right right um but you know
from what I played I think Bethesda
understands that and yeah it was it was
pretty fun so you mention motion
sickness and fallout is a game where
there is a lot of exploring a lot of
travel a lot of walking around what are
they done to actually kind of combat
that feeling sure so I think the issue
comes down to so if you were to simply
have like a joystick you know used for
movement it creates this issue called
locomotion and that it tricks your eyes
into thinking like hey you're moving but
then your body's not fooled right
so that sort of disconnect makes you
feel nauseous what possesses doing with
fallout instead is that they're using a
teleport mechanic which is you know
feature that's actually getting more
common in VR titles like the gallery and
budget cuts and things like that they're
already coming to the HTC vive already
out yeah so the really cool thing about
the game is that you actually there's no
in-game UI or menu anything like that
it's all built into the pip-boy which is
actually located on your left arm so to
actually use your pip-boy you're
bringing your physical risks with it
well the controller in hand to actually
manipulate the menu yes yeah using the
controller you have to you know bring up
your wrist and then you can see the map
and all your levelling up you know UI
from there the pit bull also allows you
to to teleport as well so you know with
my left arm I would just stick out a
point at the ground and then I'd be able
to just like let go of the trigger and I
teleport there what I noticed is that
the teleportation has like a range it
seems to be about you know forty to
fifty feet or so and I think this was
then on purpose so that if like a super
mutant is chasing you or something like
that
you can't just simply like teleport to a
mountain like cross towns yeah it makes
sense
it really feels like you're in the
wasteland like visually and so the demo
that I played actually took place at the
red rocket gas station which is like
near the beginning of the game yeah and
you know the PES the rep was like you
know don't venture too far off from here
because we're gonna have Raiders come
attack you so it's like okay cool
once the Raiders eventually showed up i
teleported or like around the corner
around the gas station and I like you
know fired at them with my pistol and
they'd fire back and dogmeat would come
and attack him I detect them and things
like that and that was really cool you
know interestingly enough the they gave
me like a pistol and I didn't have to
reload and so I had infinite ammo and
there was no bat system either okay I'm
pretty pretty odd for a fall outside I
suppose yeah yeah I think they're still
trying to work that out they haven't
ruled out you know bats at this point um
but yeah as of right now no bad system
how did the shooting in general actually
feel so obviously it being basically a
shooting game it needs to be pretty
tight it's an important mechanic yeah so
you know like it felt really one-to-one
if you've ever played a game like space
pirate rain or something very similar it
really feels like you're holding a gun
and it feels really accurate that's good
so I think the question that ever wants
to know is how was it being that close
to Dogme feeling that you can reach it
don't you I almost shot him a couple
times which is kind of a shame allowed
to do that there's one gripe that I did
have with the experience is that it
looks it looks quite real at the same
time though because the game wasn't
built for VR from the ground up there
was a lot of things that looked real but
I couldn't actually interact with them I
couldn't touch them I couldn't pick them
up conversely you know there's a game
like like a job simulator which is
actually built for vi from the ground up
and in that game you can pick up like
apples and oranges and things like that
open up the kitchen doors and throw
things across the room it feels really
good in tactile here it feels a little
bit hollow like they were like doors
that I couldn't open or there were like
tires that I couldn't pick up
and so it feels a little bit shallow so
that's kind of interesting challenge for
purpose des des to kind of figure out
there right well having said that
obviously is a demo of a game like you
said was he pre-built for for VR yeah do
you think if Bethesda had VR in mind
when they create a new title do you
think like as this demo saw which one I
did you think I'd be able to nail it
there's a couple weird things to because
like India it's in first person it's
supposed to be you right but at the same
time in the base game but the
protagonist talks so it's gonna be I
imagine it's gonna be like a weird
out-of-body experience to have like
yourself talking even though you're not
yeah so I don't know how they're gonna
work with that so I don't know alright
but it sounds interesting at least so
guys for everything VR and everything
III 2016 make sure you stay tuned to
games watch calm